welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilshire host and our guest is
Priya Natarajan a professor in the
department's of astronomy and physics at
Yale University professor Natarajan is a
theoretical astrophysicist interested in
cosmology gravitational lensing and
black hole physics her research involves
mapping the detailed distribution of
dark matter in the universe exploiting
the bending of light and route to us
from distant galaxies however we are not
here today to talk to professor in at
origin about astronomy and physics we
are going to talk with her about gender
parity issues
professor Natarajan is the current chair
of the women faculty forum at Yale and
she recently co-organized along with
Judith Resnik and Reva Siegel at the
Yale Law School the very first gruber
conference titled parity as practice the
politics of equality
welcome professor nada Rajan thank you
very much what led you to organize this
conference why do you think it is
important to have done it well first of
all it was a unique opportunity to kick
off sort of the Gruber fellowship
program moving to Yale and there seem to
be a real confluence with the goals that
the wff exemplifies in terms of exchange
of women's Scholars on issues pertinent
to women's scholarship by women on women
and also trying to understand the role
of gender the lens of gender and its and
the role that it plays in society in
many different domains so it was a lucky
coincidence that the remit of the wff
coincided with what the Gruber program
really stands for as well so we decided
to have this interdisciplinary
conference sort of an unprecedented one
really kick off a very new and important
and potentially powerful conversation
and what were some of the issues or
areas that you examines during the
conference so the notion of gender
parity is understood quite differently
in different domains okay explain that
so for example and you know understood
differently in different domains in the
public sphere in the political sphere in
universities and in the domestic sphere
and of course on top of that layering
there's a real difference in the
understanding which is culturally based
so across the world there are very
different notions of what gender parity
means and what it might look like so we
started off the conference really trying
to examine what the differences and the
similarities are in our notions of
parity for all of us situated in very
different places in the university my
particular interest is of course looking
at women in universities and in academia
in particular trying to understand what
are sort of the systemic difficulties
that women might face and how
universities what they could actually do
to ensure gender parity and sort of a
more level playing field but we examined
many different domains so we looked at
the political sphere looking at the
representation of women you know there
are some countries in the world in the
u.s. we don't have parity laws but in
many countries of the world Spain France
India Norway and Turkey they're
experimenting legally with set asides
and quotas and so we looked at that we
looked at the experience of how useful
they have been in places and how they
worked we looked at the corporate world
where again in some Nordic countries
there are requirements that there should
be 40 percent of the board of a
corporate board should be women you know
that's been in place for a short time
but we wanted to examine how that's
worked and whether that's an interesting
and useful intervention curious it's 40
percent not 50 percent that's right and
and then we looked at the domestic
sphere and you know and that's a very
fraught sphere because in a way
underlying sort of
the basis of parity is sort of how it's
played out in the domestic sphere
because you know it's the amount of work
that household work that and childcare
and nurturance that women do women tend
to do a larger share of it across the
board across cultures and that impacts
their participation in other spheres and
so then we looked at the university
sphere we looked at academia around the
world and then we also looked at gender
parity as it plays out in the
development agenda in the agenda of the
dealing with poverty dealing with women
in extremists so you know we covered a
huge sort of range and it was sort of
intentional because we wanted to learn
from practices so there are many
different meanings that people have
adopted for parity in some places gender
parity is parsed as gender equality and
in some places it is seen as under the
rubric of anti-discrimination so our
goal here was to sort of try and distill
practices and theoretical notions that
may translate across boundaries and that
we may actually find useful in our
respective spheres and both men and
women participated in the conference
absolutely but as you can probably
predict it was predominantly women
scholars it turns out and I think this
is something I really wish will change
hope I hope changes in my generation
that many of these issues actually of
gender parity are not women's issues
they're human issues and I'm really
hoping that more and more men will get
seriously drawn into this conversation
that would be very nice now in looking
at the world you touched on it briefly
how are we doing in terms of gender
parity out in the world I would imagine
some places are better than others but
is it is it is it more is it better or
is it worse percentage well you know
5050 you know country is kind of you
know moving in the right direction or is
it less than that well you know it's
very hard because then there are various
sieze along which you could measure
gender parity right and I think it would
be fair to say that it gender parity
remains an aspiration everywhere it's
not quite the reality and I think there
are a lot of contradictions right so you
may have countries where you've had a
woman head of state but doesn't doesn't
necessarily imply that the playing field
for a normal middle-class woman is any
more level or an impoverished woman is
any is in any better situation so I
think how we measure you know which
country is doing better on gender parity
issues is not so much a sort of a
national countrywide index but I think
along domains so we can see I think it
would be fair to say that women have
made great strides in all domains but
sadly there are still parts of the world
where personal safety violence against
women and sort of inequities and how the
law treats a man and a woman with
respect to marriage property etc are
still there in terms of the participants
in the conference I'm curious if and
talking about countries that have put
some kind of laws around gender issues
do people seem to think that that works
better that's more helpful towards
moving the the issue along so to speak
so it's very interesting that you ask
this because this formed one of the sort
of heated debates and the conference and
and the debate really rests around the
justification so we were trying to look
for so there's a rights theory
justification for why we need to be in a
just world and everyone needs to be
treated the same and that we form 50% of
population and so on but you know there
has been a very strong thread in society
where women have argued that on the
outcome of increased participation I
personally feel that you know there is a
justification for aspiring for gender
parity regardless of the outcome so I
think the question of whether having 40
percent women in power
and actually translates into being
better for women overall is not the
question to ask really it's hard to
assess and I think the report on that is
mixed for instance in local government
for example in India where they required
50% women some studies show that women
once they are elected into these
positions tend to focus on issues that
are tantamount and important to them
like water so water is an issue in India
and women often are carry water too for
their household so women in these local
governments tended to use start off with
water as a priority
however it's it's as I said it's mix
because if you look at the Nordic
countries what they found is when you
had 40 percent women in the national
legislature so we're talking about the
national level not the local level here
for the first six months or so we heard
reports that women focused on what we
would see as traditional sort of women's
agendas but then within six months there
was actually no difference and men and
women pushed very very similar agendas
so I think the question of whether the
outcomes are better for women is a
fraught question and I think what we
really need to focus on is that having a
more sort of even participation is good
for society as a whole
so what were some of the outcomes of the
conference so in one of the interesting
you know so first of all having a
conference like this with all these
different voices representing so many
exemplary scholars and activists was a
feat in and of itself and the fact that
we started a very important what we feel
is a very important interesting
conversation that can move forward that
can be helpful for people across domains
was one you know it was one in which we
are hoping to start new collaborations
intellectual collaborations as well as
learn sort of practical things from each
other so it was I think I see it as a
great success because it was the start
of a very novel conversation that hasn't
happened before and what do you think it
would take for
gender parity to actually happen and do
you think it's achievable well well I
hope it's achievable and I hope it's
achievable
during my lifetime but I think that the
notion used to be for example if you
look at the university's domain that you
know it's a question of time we just
don't have we have this metaphor of a
pipeline we just don't have enough women
coming through particularly in the STEM
fields the science technology and
mathematics engineering and mathematics
fields that there aren't enough women
who were starting off as undergraduate
so we don't have enough in the pool to
pick professors from and so on so forth
but it turns out that with all the work
and the awareness for the past 20 years
you know the pipeline is now populated
so it is no longer a question of just
time but you know we'll catch up in time
I think the things that really need work
on for achieving parity are the more in
insidious complicated subtle things and
they are sort of sort of the gender
stereotyping implicit absolutely
unconscious bias and so and I think what
we really need to think hard about for
every domain in society is what are the
little nudges that are needed to get
people to start examining their own
stereotypes men and women not just men
men and how do you facilitate those
nudges absolutely and how do you
incentivize them how do you first make
people aware of them and then how do you
incentivize people to actually change
and as you can imagine right in the
domain of science in STEM fields it's
particularly difficult because in these
disciplines which we all as
practitioners feel that we are objective
we are just and we are fair and that we
have very clear-cut criteria to
understand what is good scholarship and
what isn't you know it is not about
weighing one argument against the other
so you know it's a more so we feel and
so for us to accept that we have
unconscious biases is a huge challenge
but I think that's really where the
future a challenge is for for us of
course there are societies where the
challenges are more fundamental
with regard to sort of Human Rights
basic human rights but you know as I
said the challenges are very different
in very in in the various domains but I
think there's no escape that even once
we get the numbers up that there are
other more subtle barriers that we need
to tackle and that's the real challenge
for the future okay very good thank you
so much for being here today and sharing
some of the work that was done at the
conference thank you so much I'm happy
to be here for more information about
Professor Nataraja and her work please
visit our website at Yale edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale